all right hi everyone my name is Daniel
raw I'm a program manager on the asp.net
team and I'm thrilled to be able to talk
to you about building amazing web apps
with dotnet core and Visual Studio 2019
Visual Studio 2019 comes with the latest
version of.net core in the box.net cor
2:2
donít core 2 2 is loaded with a lot of
great new features we've done a lot of
work on the templates to simplify them
clean them up we've updated them to use
bootstrap for we also updated the
angular template to use angular 6
angular 7 will be coming in the next
release we did a lot of work on Web API
improvements in particular we provide
now API analyzers and conventions that
make it easy to generate complete
swagger documents or open API
specifications for your AP is we added
HTTP to support to kestrel our
cross-platform web server and we also
enabled in process hosting support for
IAS we added a new health checks
framework and also a new routing
framework that we call endpoint routing
let me go ahead and show you what it
looks like to do web development with
Visual Studio 2019 and dotnet core 2.2
all right so let's go over here to
Visual Studio I'm gonna great create a
new a speed on it core web application
web application 1 sounds great I'm gonna
put it in my demo folder that looks good
let's create that ok now you'll notice
at the top that asp.net core 2 2 is
already selected
I installed two two of dotnet core when
I installed the web work load and the
dotnet core work load as part of the
Visual Studio 2019 installation
alright let's create a web application
that looks great create that and this
will go ahead and generate my project
for me alright so we're gonna wait for
the package restore just to complete and
then we'll go ahead and build and run
this and see what the template looks
like there it goes all right there so
let's build and run it while we're
waiting for it to build and run if we
look at this template hopefully you can
see that it's a you know a lot more
lightweight there's a lot fewer files in
this template we've done some work to
try and slim it
get rid of the stuff that you end up
having to just delete whenever you start
a new project so you can get going
faster with your new applications here's
the application up and running now
waiting for it to render there it is and
you can see now the the new templates
and HP asp.net core 2.2 they're a lot
cleaner a lot simpler a lot fresher
looking and this is all based on
bootstrap 4 we go looking at the layout
for this application should see
bootstrap 4 in here and there it is
bootstrap 4 is wired up by default this
application is also using eius express
to to host the application let's do
something real quick let's go into the
home page of the app and what I'm going
to do inside a header here and let's
print out the name of the current
process that the app is running in so
right Diagnostics process get current
process and then the process name there
we go so let's just save that and then
I'll refresh the home page of the
application we should now see the the
process that the app is running in and
it's running in the is Express process
this is different than earlier versions
of.net core and asp.net core in earlier
versions your app would run in a dotnet
eggsy process and then IAS would proxy
requests to your application and they
had a number of issues it had a
performance hit and also me if anything
went wrong with your net XE process then
it was hard to diagnose what happened
there in starting in dotnet cor 2:2
you can now host your asp.net core apps
directly in the is process much better
performance much easier to debug and
diagnose issues so that's great alright
let's go back to the app instead of
running this app and is Express and
that's let's now flip it to just be a
standalone application basically a
console app hosting an asp.net core
application and let's go ahead and run
that and now we should see the the
process should change because we're no
longer using is at all so you would
expect to be back to just running in a
normal dotnet eggsy process and we are
great
let's pop up the the the browser dev
tools and look at the network trace as
we refresh the application there's all
the files that are being downloaded
notice that all these files by default
are being downloaded over HTTP 1 1 but
we in
cor 2:2 we've added support for http/2
to kestrel it's not on by default you
have to enable it but it's really easy
to do let's go ahead and do that I've
got a little code snippet here and
notepad I'm just going to copy out let's
grab that and then go back to the
application we'll stop it and then
update our where we're building up the
the web host so let's go ahead and add a
little bit of code here to configure
kestrel and I think we need a namespace
yes we do great so here you can see
we're now enabling both HTTP 1 and HB 2
protocols
we're setting up HTTPS so that we can do
negotiation 2 with the browser to set up
HTTP 2 all right let's let's now rerun
this application running on Castrol and
see if we see any difference ok we're
back in the browser still running on net
let's look at the browser dev tools and
refresh the application and voila
instead of HP 1.1 you now see the
protocol is h2 which is short for HTTP 2
and this is great because it means we
can take advantage of features like
connection reuse compressed headers and
all the optimizations that come with
using the HB 2 protocol cool all right
what about Web API development with
dotnet core 2.2 let's go ahead and close
the browser and close this app and let's
open up a different project I was
working earlier on an API in my my pets
API when my favorites a favorite API is
to work on this is an API intended to
manage a list of pets that you can add
pets get the full list of pets and so
forth simple crud operations lets
already started a little bit here I
define my model type here's my pet class
it has an ID and a name ok now I want to
create an API controller based off of
this model so I'm gonna use Visual
Studio to help me do that
let's add a new controller all right I'm
gonna create an API controller with
actions using entity framework so any
framework will be used to actually store
the pet data let's add that for the
model class let's use pet I already have
a data context class I'll just reuse and
for the controller class name pets
controller sounds great so we'll go
ahead and generate that now visual
studio is going to take care of
generating for me an entire API
controller class with action methods
that
all the standard crud crud actions like
get post put and delete and all the code
for interacting with any data framework
or has already done for me so that's
great so I've got my API all set to go
here now I've also already gone into
this project and enabled swagger
generation or open API spec generation
which is sort of the newer name to do
that I use a great open-source community
project called swashbuckle you can see
here that I've got the swashbuckle
package added to this application
already swashbuckle asp net core and
then if we go into startup you can see
that I've already wired it up added the
swagger generation services and then
down below in my configure method added
the endpoints for generating the swagger
document and exposing the swagger UI so
I should be able to now just run this
application and see the default swagger
UI showing me the my new API resource
let's see if that works
ok great we're at the swagger UI and
there's my pets API awesome and there's
the default values API that just comes
with the template and if we look through
this so that we see all the things we
expect we can get the list of pets where
you can post new pads we can get
individual pads delete them and so forth
alright not but something doesn't look
quite satisfactory quite complete like
if we look at say the post action in the
responses section it says that this
thing basically always returns 200 okay
pretty sure that's not the case like
there might be you know errors
validation errors or I'm pretty sure
that but normally in response to a post
you would say well a resource has been
recreated you've posted a new resource
201 created here's the URL to the new
resource but that's not here that's not
missing is it in the code let's go look
at our pets controller again and look
for the post action where is it
so there's put yeah here's post and yeah
there's a the returned value is it
created at action action result which
yeah it says returns a 201 that's not
documented in the swagger document why
is that well there's only so much that
libraries like swashbuckle can do by
just statically analyzing your api's to
figure out what the swagger
documents should be what the open API
spec should say some things you have to
tell swashbuckle about using attributes
and additional metadata this is one of
those cases
fortunately in dotnet cor 2:2
we give you an analyzer an API analyzer
we can see it in the analyzer section
there it is I've got it already added to
this project that will look at your API
controller and tell you about all the
places where you probably should add
some additional metadata in fact you can
see I'm already getting a green squiggle
here from my post action with a
potential fix up if I go ahead and do
the fix-up I get the attributes that I
would expect saying that this action by
the way returns a 201 created so if we
rerun this application now hopefully our
post action in the swagger document
should look a little bit more
descriptive let's see if that's the case
post and yes all right so now it says
that returns a 201 which is awesome also
it has like a default response which
would be like in response to errors and
the nice thing here is in that in
asp.net cor 2:2 we added support for
problem details which is a standardized
RFC I think it's RFC 7800 seven there it
is for generating machine readable error
responses so that's already configured
for you and setup for for your API
controller awesome alright so that looks
good but it would be kind of tedious to
go through and add all these attributes
to all of my actions is there a better
way and of course the answer is yes
instead of adding the attributes to each
and every one of your actions you can
instead apply an API Convention which
looks at the patterns that your methods
match and applies metadata accordingly
and we give you a set of API conventions
out-of-the-box that match the API
conventions that we generate in our
scaffolded code until you apply those
you just use the API Convention type
attribute there if there was there it is
and then the default API conventions
that we provide are this default API
conventions type all right cool let me
save that actually let me copy comment
that out and then down below if we look
in the errors list see the API analyzer
is telling me about all the different
action method
that are missing you know metadata about
the response types if I now uncomment
the convention and again look at the
error list poof
they've all gone away everything has
been fixed up for me if I now run the
application one more time hopefully our
swagger swagger swagger document is much
more descriptive let's see so like the
get that takes an ID that you would
expect to return 200 ok if it's exceeded
yeah 404 if the ID is not found d up and
then the default for errors and so forth
so great now we have a really complete
open API specification all right cool
so that's know some of the new features
that are in dotnet core 2.2 used within
Visual Studio 2019 there are also a
bunch of really great razor tooling
improvements in Visual Studio 2019 razor
is the format that we use to generate
HTML dynamically using a combination of
HTML and C sharp some of the
improvements that we've added for razor
in Visual Studio 2019 is support for
find all references modern completions
and of course live share so let's go
take a look at that all right back to
Visual Studio 2019 let's open up a
different project this is just an
asp.net core web app but I've done a
little bit more to this application here
I wanted to generate some pages for
managing products so I've defined a
product model type it has an ID a name
and a price and then I went and
scaffolded a bunch of razor pages this
time some UI no no not an API controller
but some some razor pages and the way I
did that I already I've already done it
but you can do it yourself to just add
razor page and then razor pages using
entity framework that's the one we want
add that and then here I specified my
product type for the model I use my
existing data contacts class and then
accepted all the defaults and clicked
add and after I did that and went ahead
and generated all of these knives razor
pages for me which is great ok so let's
go ahead and run this app and let's see
what it's got
so let's see we should see our normal
default template that we saw before with
a nice bootstrap for based clean UI and
then hopefully some pages for looking at
products and we go so we got a product
tab up here that I added and let's see
yeah so we've got a list of products so
what do we got we got a razor we've got
a blazer blazer is of course free
because you know it doesn't cost any
code to write c-sharp and then asp net
an asp net I assume that's some sort of
net for catching poisonous snakes or
something like that I can almost hear
the groans coming through the through
the camera yeah so we've got a list of
of products here we can edit things like
if we wanted to go in here and actually
put you know make this a snit core and
make that free as well that looks good
so we can you can edit you can delete
you can list the products awesome
alright but let's go look at the the
razor files and see what Visual Studio
2019 can do for us let's see let's first
look at let's look at find all
references ok so I'm looking at the
product type and you can see through
code lens that it's telling me all the
places where the product type is being
used and you know if I just look at the
type it shows up in all these c-sharp
files these are all the code-behind
files for the razor pages that's the way
final references has always supported
that that's that's that's normal and
expected but what's really cool now is
that if I looked at what look at one of
the members for my product type and
let's expand that a little bit so we can
see it better now we can see all the
places where that that member is being
used in razor files like here's the
exact line where that that property is
being used so find our references now
works with with razor which is great
what else let's go into the index page
for this application let's say we wanted
to add a directive like let's add an
inject directive for like injecting a
service into this page I start typing at
in I course get completions over razor
directives and all the c-sharp stuff but
the nice thing is because we're in
Visual Studio 2019 I'm sorry let me let
me start that again because we're in
Visual Studio 2019 we are using the new
modern completions infrastructure so I
can actually filter the completions by
just the razor directives you see that
says razor directives on that button and
so I get just razor direct
does when I type that okay let's go back
to the add-in and filter the Razr
directives and then we can complete it
awesome and then you could type your
type here and so forth so that's modern
completions with razor lastly what if
you need some help with your your
asp.net core project and you're working
with you know razor pages or views and
you want it to help from your buddy
well you can do that using live share
now so I'm gonna go ahead and set up a
live search session for this visual
studio instance okay let's go ahead and
do that and this should then copy a URL
to the clipboard yep there did that I
can now share with my buddy who can help
me out now to emulate my buddy I'm just
gonna open up another visual studio 2019
instance and let's join that live share
session alright so we're just gonna do
file join lives there share session and
paste that URL in there and join it okay
while it's joining us gonna put these
two visual studio instances side-by-side
alright so we got nothing yet well it
says that that I joined the live share
share session remotely from you know
whatever part of the world okay I can
see some of the solution now showing up
and there's the Razr file in fact it
even shows where my cursor is that and
now I can go ahead and start writing
just normal Razer code like let me help
you out there Dan you wanted to display
the current time here no problem the
current date is at date and I get C
sharp completions in Razer running in
live share dot now yet more c-sharp
completions works awesome okay now and
if I look at what's actually on disk in
this guest visual studio instance in
this this that's joined the live share
session let's open the containing folder
you'll see that you know I've got like
nothing here like this all I've got is
this you know pretty much empty project
and the files that I have that's that
have been shared with me so far that
I've been editing so I can write Razer
code get c-sharp completions for a
remote ace panic asp.net core project
that's using eraser that's pretty cool
so that's live share let's go ahead and
leave the session and shut that down
there we go okay there's some of your
new razor tooling features in Visual
Studio 2019 all right let's look to the
future now when we can write client-side
web applications using dotnet instead of
JavaScript we have been working to make
it possible for you to write reusable
web UI components using c-sharp and
razor that can run directly in the
browser and this is great because it
enables you to share dotnet code both on
the server and on the client you can
have shared common logic if you still
want to call in JavaScript you can do
that too you can call in to existing
JavaScript libraries browser API is
using a JavaScript Interop and for the
initially we will support two Hosting
models for these kinds of applications
we will support hosting these apps on a
server where all of the UI interactions
with the browser get handled over a
signaler connection or we will also
support hosting these applications
client-side in the browser on top of web
assembly now what is web assembly well
web assembly is a relatively new open
web standard that defines a bytecode for
the web and what this means is that as
long if you have some code as long as
you can compile it to web assembly it
can now run in any browser at near
native speed this is awesome because it
means now when you want to write web
client-side web logic you can pretty
much do it in whatever language or
framework you want and of course we want
dotnet to run great on web assembly so
we've been working on that for a while
with this project that we call blazer
now what is blazer well blazer you can
either run a blazer app directly in the
browser on web assembly writing
components getting rich interactive UI
or alternatively you can write a blazer
app same components and host its
server-side in asp.net core and handle
all the UI interactions with the browser
over a signal our connection now
initially we will support the
server-side hosting model for dotnet
core 3 Oh later
the future as soon as the webassembly
dotnet runtime is ready we will ship
support for client-side blazer at some
future point let me show you what it's
like to do blazer development with
Visual Studio 2019 okay now these are
actually you know brand new bits
hot-off-the-press I'm actually going to
shift over to a developer build a visual
studio with some some some updates and
I'm using dotnet core 3 o on this
machine now initially what I've got here
is a server-side blazer application it
has the number of components that are
implemented using these dot RAZR files
let's just run the app so we can see
what it looks like
alright so it compile and get this get
it get it running and actually this app
actually starts up pretty fast and it
has some nice functionality you can
click a counter and the counter goes up
you have a fetch data page that's
retrieving some some data and then
rendering a table and then we have sort
of a blank - duze page now normally to
get this type of behavior we would have
interactivity where I click a button the
UI just updates without a page refresh
normally you'd have to do that using
JavaScript but I didn't write any
JavaScript to write this application it
was all implemented in c-sharp and razor
here's the counter component it has a
page directive at the top to say that
this is a routable component then some
normal HTML markup we use some razor
syntax to write out the current count
then we have a button with an onclick
handler normally this would be
JavaScript but we're using razor syntax
to say no I want to run some she's
c-sharp code here here's the method that
we're going to call every single time
that button is clicked let's actually
run this in the bugger
the app up and running again and then
we'll go ahead and set a breakpoint on
the increment count method all right
counter we click the button and boom
we're hitting c-sharp code all right so
that's super cool let's go ahead and let
this run through how is this working
well if we look at the the browser
developer tools let's refresh this you
can see this app's actually pretty
lightweight it's only got a few hundred
kilobytes of downloaded payload but
there is a WebSocket connection that
gets set up with a server every time I
click this button we hit our breakpoint
again let's go ahead and uncheck that
and let it flow through you can see that
bytes are flying along that WebSocket
connection talking to the server running
your components and then the UI updates
get gets sent back that is the
server-side Blaser model now in the
future we also want to support running
those same components client-side in the
browser on web assembly let me show you
that so I've got a different project
here this is blazer on web assembly
alright let's go ahead and get this guy
up and running now the code looks
exactly the same we've got a counter
component with the same code that you
saw before same component model but
hosted in a different way
alright so here what the behavior looks
the same we have a counter have a fetch
data page that's act this case it's
actually fetching us some JSON data from
the server deserializing it in the
browser and rendering this table if we
look at the network trace for for this
application it's pulling down a little
bit more stuff but some really cool
stuff if we looked at in here where is
it so mano
this guy mano azzam that is a full
dotnet runtime implemented in web
assembly and then below you have normal
dotnet DLL is being downloaded and
executed directly in the browser to show
it to really prove to you that this is
actually dotnet code running in the
browser let's do this I'm gonna do some
debugging let's now this debugging is
gonna happen actually directly in the
browser with the browser dev tools to do
that I need to enable remote debugging
with the browser so let me just copy
this command not that copy that good and
then we'll close all the browser tabs
real quick and it'll restart the browser
with remote debugging enabled and then
we'll fire up the debugger again and see
if we can debug our c-sharp code that's
executing client-side okay there
here's the browser dev tools let me put
this side-by-side with the browser
alright
now you'll notice I concede that D
allows in the sources for this
application you can expand the client
DLL and see my counter component I can
even set a breakpoint on the counter
click the button and there we just hit a
breakpoint in c-sharp code running on a
web assembly based on at runtime
executing directly in the browser this
is something that we expect to ship in
the future alright so that is Blaser in
Visual Studio 2019 I hope you enjoyed
learning about web development with the
latest version of Visual Studio please
download the bits and try it out
fantastic are we ready for questions
absolutely fantastic alright so by the
way your questions are super important
so get them in use the hash IDs 2019
we'll get them on the board
and we'll make sure to ask them if your
question gets asked during the show you
will win an answer to the question
hopefully hopefully hopefully hopefully
all right so here is I need ket I think
I got the answer I talk about new CS
proj file is there a new OCS proj file
or is it the same as old I mean well
there there is a sort of a newer flavor
of CS proj that we use in dotnet core
applications that is much you know much
lighter weight like there's not much
going on in those in the CS Braj files
that are wearing the applications that I
created you don't have to list every
single file that's that's in the project
you get to use packaged references
directly in the CS proj yeah there's a
we've done a lot of work to try and make
C a surprise you know cleaner lighter
weight easier to use fantastic from Cal
when do you recommend use razor pages
versus MVC I feel like that question
maybe you can help they're both great
they're both awesome technologies so
razor pages was introduced later and
it's actually built on top of MVC it's
kind of a non question because if you're
using razor pages you are using MVC
every razor page is actually running on
top of the MVC infrastructure razor
pages is kind of nice because it's a
page based model if you just if you want
to page you just create a page and then
that the the route for that that page is
just the place of that page on the the
directory on the folder structure NBC
gives you a little bit more I would say
d-cup
in terms of how your project is
structured where your views are over
here and your controllers are over there
a lot of people really like that that
model but both are great both are
testable both can scale to large
applications
I think razor pages is probably an
easier place to start if you haven't
done any development with MBC before or
asp.net core I would probably start out
with razor pages
it's basically do whatever makes you
happy that's true and whatever you would
like
I think you'll be happy with either of
them yeah whatever you'd like to retain
all right so from Remy swagger looks
great but is there a way to
automatically create model classes based
on swagger and point just like the old
good one add service reference it's ask
me because I'm pretty sure it's possible
and V is 2019 so there is there is some
support for code generation in Visual
Studio 2019 for doing client code
generation based on an open API spec or
a swagger document we're actually
working on a major turn of the crank on
that infrastructure for the.net course
real wave where we will have really
great support for doing ms build based
code generation from your API so it'll
be really easy to on every build will
generate the code it'll always be up to
date we're actually working with a bunch
of really good community projects on
that as well and swag has some
functionality that we're leveraging for
this feature
yeah there's stuff that's the stuff
that's coming awesome next question is
blazer now officially and more than just
the nice to have maybe in a pre-alpha
mode by air quoted that for you yeah and
fully supported the new BS version so
blazer started out as an experimental
project right we were trying playing
around with web assembly could could we
get dotnet to work on web assembly is
that even possible we weren't even sure
if people wanted it we've been doing
that experiment now for a little over a
year we're pretty much at the tail end
of that experiment where we're pretty
sure that a yes absolutely we can do
this and be a lot of people tell us that
they really would like it it's still
technically experimental right now but I
can sort of see the the end in sight
soon for that for the experimental phase
of blazer the model of taking the same
components and running them server-side
where you manage all the UI interactions
over a signal our connection
we call that server-side blazer that is
shipping in dotnet course Rio absolutely
like when Winnetka Rio
ships you can use that in productions
that will probably come first and then
as soon as the webassembly based on at
runtime ISM is ready we will then have
production ready support for client-side
laser running in the browser and web
assembly I was there at NDC Oslo when
Sanderson was like hey do you want to
see some code I wrote just a demo little
demo I did it over the weekend he was
peod broking into javascript files
because that's what you would do with
blazer right I mean I was like that's uh
oh my goodness yes that's what it would
be you know all I know is it was a
Fowler and Edwards we were all just
sitting there like this what did what is
this it's it's pretty cool that it's
advanced all the way to where I'm seeing
a lot of people up taking this pretty
exciting I think yeah we're we're
excited about it having speaker spoke
speaking of that haven't spoken of my
English is terrible today Allah what is
the expected arrival date for blazer on
the client well we don't have officially
publicly announced release date I can
tell you that the client blazer support
won't be available with donek or 3yo
like we'll ship down at core 3 o first
and then blazer client side I expect
will come sometime later how soon later
is what we're actually really actively
working it on right now like it's really
depends on how fast can we stabilize and
mature the webassembly story for dotnet
all up stay tuned for that like
hopefully we'll have answers to that
question that are more concrete in the
near future fantastic just two more
questions will there be interrupts
between web assembly and JavaScript to
allow for continuous delivery
replacement of application functionality
so you can there's probably two
questions in there you can of course
call into JavaScript from webassembly
that that works you can call from dotnet
code into any JavaScript library any
browser API in fact you can even take
those libraries written in JavaScript
and sort of shrink wrap them in a dotnet
API wrapper ship him as a nougat package
and now anyone can call that library as
if it was written in c-sharp and net
there seemed to be some hint in that
question that they also wanted to be
able to sort of like dynamically update
parts of the app that is like a more
like a hot module reloading I'm antic
that is something that we have been
talking about and looking at potential
solutions
really concrete to share on that yet
though awesome well we're gonna finish
with that thanks so much Dan for
spending some time with us